over the last 48 hours we have seen an
incredible shift where Donald Trump has
signaled that if only 200,000 people die
of coronavirus in the United States that
would be considered a very good job we
are seeing such a goalpost move here
that it might actually trick his
followers because of how drastically the
goal posts are being moved I want to
remind you we have an incompetent failed
response to the virus this has resulted
in Trump's last tool so to speak which
is gaslighting his followers so that
they will hopefully forget that just a
few weeks ago Trump was talking about
we've got 15 cases and that number will
soon be zero other countries were acting
like adults they were preparing for the
pandemic here is Trump Sunday saying you
know if we end up with no more than
200,000 people dying not cases deaths
okay
that would be a very good job and Trump
sort of cleverly mentioning you know one
estimate said 2.2 million might die if
we can keep it to 200,000 deaths that
would be a big very good job that we did
not so you're talking about 2.2 million
deaths 2.2 million people from this and
so if we can hold that down as we're
saying to a hundred thousand it's a
horrible number maybe even less but to a
hundred thousand so we have between 100
and 200,000 we all together have done a
very good job but so recall that Trump
tweeted on March 9th that this is
nothing compared to the flu because the
flu might kill 27,000 to 70,000 people
saying quote so last year 37 thousand
Americans died from the common flu it
averaged is 27 to 70,000 per year
nothing is shut down life and the
economy go on at this moment there are
546 confirmed cases of corona virus with
22 deaths think about that now at the
time 22 deaths
now
and climbing in the United States and
the same Trump who said this isn't as
bad as the flu sometimes up to 70,000
died of the flu each year rarely but
sometimes he's now saying if we stay
below 200,000 deaths not cases we will
have done a good job remember here was
Trump saying we have 15 cases and it
will soon be zero we've done really an
extraordinary job when you look at a
country this size with so many people
pouring in with the number one in the
world for people coming into a country
by far and we have a total of 15 cases
and again when you have 15 people and
the 15 within a couple of days is going
to be down to close to zero that's a
pretty good job we've done and now if we
don't lose more than 200,000 people
it means Trump did a very good job this
is a hell of a lot of deaths for
something that five weeks ago was
nothing and just the latest democratic
hoaxes so it's really really important
that we don't take our eye off the ball
this is a pandemic this is a tragedy
at some point we will get past it we
will have some death toll the latest
estimates are about 83,000 for this wave
we could then have a second wave in the
fall and another wave in 2021 we could
get to 200,000 by the time it's all said
and done we don't know yet but at some
point it's going to be done we can't
forget the incompetence and the lying
and the deception and say hey we made it
those of us that do make it and
hopefully as many of us as possible will
be in that group we have to remember
that we've been led by one of the worst
responses in the world to the virus
maybe Iran did worse I don't know China
lied a lot sure but look at how quickly
South Korea developed and deployed a
test they had their first case on the
same day we did South Korea has a
hundred and fifty deaths total not in
one day total we have hundreds dying
every day it appears it will
be thousands dying per day we need to
ensure that there is a consequence for
Trump and now this framing that he's
doing of listen it's a big win if we
keep the death toll to 200,000 he
previously said we have a few cases it
will soon be none we now are having
potentially hundreds of thousands of
deaths we can't let him get away with it
his followers are going to we can't
enough of us have to remember that we
need a change in November of 2020 so
that he cannot get away with this there
are medical components here there are
social social cultural components here
economic there are so many
considerations but we've been failed by
the Trump administration and there has
to be a consequence for that I don't
know if there will be but I hope there
is